uh what up drum alert nation
this is your host killer keemstar let's
get
right ethan come on ethan
you are such a hypocrite okay keemstar
settle
just keep getting beard fibers in my
mouth either who are you dressed says
um the greatest artist of our generation
oliver tree ethan how dare you even ask
me who i am setting you up i know what
though
how dare you ask me who i am i was just
trying to set you up so that you could
intro yourself i know okay i'm just
gonna walk out
i'm just gonna walk out at this rate
you're doing the oliver
what the [ __ ] it's really good what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
which is a very disturbing zack a very
very disturbing mask
that looks insane where did you get that
yeah
you actually sold them on his uh website
so uh
pretty good price pick one up and be
great
yeah i didn't that's kind of that is
kind of a good merch item to be
totally freak how much was it it was
like 20 bucks wasn't that bad
where does he source his masks uh that's
amazing they're good
[Music]
big head is a [ __ ] hypocrite [ __ ] you
big ed all you do is scam your fans okay
keemstar not now we're trying to
introduce the show big head is a
[ __ ] hypocrite all right keemstar
come on
relax i also have a jar of mayonnaise of
course
excellent high budget costume
how much was that jar of mayonnaise uh
like seven dollars and i thought to
start halloween off right
i would take a sacrificial
bite of mayonnaise if that's okay
[Applause]
zach from the h3 podcast is such a
[ __ ] hypocrite
he says he doesn't he likes horsey sauce
but he only eats mayonnaise on the show
what the [ __ ] is up with that well
that's a good point keemstar but okay
let's see
he says he's gonna eat the whole jar of
mayonnaise but he only took one spoonful
he's a [ __ ] hypocrite oh god you guys
ready
yeah wait does keemstar's uh legal team
approve of this
did you consult your lady i have a team
of lawyers
following your every move ela the horse
lady
and unless you want to get sued
i would advise you to go
did you just call me ela yeah i called
you either the horse lady
you just want me to walk out of here
today right okay you just want me to
walk
too complicated too many layers
what the [ __ ] that go ahead go ahead and
christen us with the mayonnaise it would
you please
here we go are you guys ready a little
asmr yes sir
oh yes round of applause
round of applause
a round of applause for zach oh he's
gagging we'd love to see you
what happened zach you're losing your
will
[Laughter]
a little under the weather today so it's
not really
great on the tummy okay
zach says he would eat the whole jar and
now he's taking one bite
he is scamming his fans and he is a
[ __ ]
hypocrite
well do it on camera oh [ __ ]
that was your idea i didn't expect that
to happen
anything for the show thank you well
almost
anything for almost anything i found
zach's boundary but i won't say what it
was
oh yeah there was something came up he
told me not to talk about it
so almost anything for the show but okay
this beard is gonna be hard to maintain
the whole we have thank you zach
that was a very uh do you want to do one
more are we done
i'll do one more you want more one more
one more one a smaller one a smaller one
one more
[Laughter]
the sound guy exposed
all right we'll go back to zach and get
updates on his health let's throw it to
ian aien who is the imposter apparently
which is funny because he's an imposter
among humans is that the
idea there ian ain uh no i wasn't me i
was in electrical the whole time
yeah i think ethan's looking a little
sus though if i gotta be
all right tough guys let's move on out
of here
simmer down and then we've got uh dan
da da da da dan who is dan
oh you know who i am baby talk to me
baby
baby let's see those arms those sleeves
let's go
it's just really hard to concentrate i'm
looking over there at aiea
oh my gosh yeah he does look good today
but wow
oh my god try to keep it professional um
we are doing a show here vin diesel
if you would please just simmer down
and then finally we have a little video
introduction for our next
uh cast member so here it is
oh do we already start oh my bed i'll be
right there
[Music]
okay let's do this
casey neistat boosted boarded
five feet to his desk very nice
we love to see it so you
you're the casey that's still in new
york yeah
i'm in new york casey i just ran here
actually from california
can you do a casey neistat uh impression
for us what would he say if you are him
right now i said hey it's
casey neistat uh
everybody go vote that sounds
right i don't know why i didn't know
this
k-pop uh i forgot about that
people are saying a b nice dad hey nice
that
is such a fraud he
literally moved to l.a from new york he
is such
a libtard wow he is the definition of
what happens when a libtard
moves from new york to l.a singapore
hypocrite
oh god
so as you guys guessed it's halloween
it's the last
episode before halloween oh we have a
sponsor today
oh fantastic who is it today's episode
is brought to you by
ring ring you know we love it
perfect from vin diesel cause he'll use
it to like spy on people changing and
stuff
talk to me baby talk to me baby
no you can't do that with ring it's a
big just
yeah it's not a that's not what ring is
for okay
here let me close this let me open my
dock so how's everybody doing on this
beautiful
uh halloween eve halloween eve i mean
it's tomorrow we could call it halloween
eve
we're actually doing halloween on
halloween eve eve
yeah close that's about as close as we
ever got you know
this is you know it's funny everybody's
always waiting for halloween to be on a
weekend because usually it's in the
middle of the week and you can't really
enjoy it
but now that it's on a saturday
obviously we have coved and so that kind
of spoils the fun
i think did they cancel halloween in la
dan because the last i heard they're
like uh you really
you can't go out i think they've they
forbade it yeah
oh did they really because i've i've
heard they flip-flopped it but they
flip-flop a few times
i'm not sure what's the status can
someone tell me if i'm allowed to
are people going to be trick-or-treating
gavin newsom
is a [ __ ] hypocrite
there is a pandemic so it's not that
simple
um oh this be i don't know if i can
hang with this beard to be honest with
you it's so
fur it's hot dude it's furry man
zach you're not gonna wear that thing
the whole episode what's going on
i'm just recovering from that mayonnaise
i gotta take this off i gotta i have to
take the beard off this is gonna be a
very long show that's okay you've done
your part on the whole i was like dude
i feel like i have done my part this
halloween you know what i mean
thank you elo i want to say on the
that not only is it almost halloween the
election is on tuesday
yeah which might be my last chance to
directly speak on this before it happens
but
i would encourage you all to vote
your hearts out okay
trump doesn't like to hear that but just
[ __ ] vote you know what i mean
you know it's funny the more people that
vote
just vote it's important just get out
there and do it all right
you know you know i'm following this
these trump these the trump family like
you know we yesterday we had 88 000 new
covet cases which is a world
wow oh wow when did this turn into kovid
world
that's really him yeah that sounds like
your voice filter
that's not slowed down or anything
that's the real deal
that is uh that's actually him
holy
he's mongolian throat singing but anyway
you know
they just lie and they're i don't know
what they're getting at but like
you know eric trump is on fox news
yesterday going
we're turning the corner the deaths are
down you know a thousand people
died that day there's the deaths are
going to be going up i think to about
two thousand a day
i think the the daily covet amounts are
gonna be going up to
over a hundred thousand certainly i mean
150 000
and it's starting to get into really
scary numbers now because like the
i saw dr ding show that like the last
million of new cases happened so fast
oh yeah like we're in total 9 million
right yeah and i think the last million
was like over 14 days or something where
before it was like months
because it's just now accelerating yeah
and um
i mean people go people like to say
deaths are down
people are recovering i mean trump is
always saying we're doing more tests
which
which i guess is true in a vacuum but
literally all you have to do is look at
hospitalizations going up every day by
thousands
hospitalizations are up to 45 000 which
is almost up to our world record
i'm just saying that this dude is going
to [ __ ]
just think this you can't reopen the
country until you get coveted under
control that's my opinion
i mean makes sense right it doesn't
really make sense yes give you a big
fat kiss yeah okay so that's that's
pretty much for me it comes down to
we need to stop this [ __ ] and
carry the [ __ ] on and that's why i'll be
voting
for i'll be writing in oliver tree slash
eloquent
you know what the more i i know we
goofed on joe biden like a lot sloppy
joe and all that but
the more i'm following him the more i
like i think he's a
decent guy i like kamala too
kamal i know less about i know dan has
problems with her
right dan dan's not here he blew it we
got vin here
he blew it anyway that's my plug go to
joe
three oh yeah he's a gas machine
for sure yeah
ethan is a [ __ ] political hack
how dare you tell your fans who you're
voting for
okay keemstar it's not a big deal i know
who you're voting for you're always
endorsing trump [ __ ] you ethan
trump is a businessman and he will run
this country like a business
bankrupt it all right keemstar
you're a lion dog face pony soldier
keemstar you're a lying dog face pony so
okay okay you gotta bring your pop up
more in
screen oh
[Music]
i'm not gonna be able to do the show
with this puppet on my hand it might be
time to retire the puppet
really already
i pushed it too far already okay guys
well we got our answer right
go ahead and play the one i told you
never to play zach play just do it it's
halloween
let's go it's halloween no don't play it
it might we might get our
video death to all jews
[Laughter]
he literally did that you know you know
he uh
he made it a twitter video once
where he said everybody go tweet to
ethan death told jews
right uh zach i was
[ __ ] stuff to all jews i yes i said
death to all jews but i was kidding
it was taken out of contact
all right taking it off all right let's
do a show here today we're
supposed to we're we're 15 minutes in
should probably start vin diesel what do
you know about show
making a show i'm mr show business baby
all right oh so there's some some
exciting news
on next week we're starting a new weekly
series called make ethan laugh which is
a spin-off of our the world famous
make ethan laugh segment this is going
to be a 30 minute
live show where people call in and make
me
stone-faced ethan klein laugh for a
hundred dollars
wow when's the first episode on
wednesday uh that's what
uh yeah wednesday what's good for pst
what did you say wednesday at 12 pst
oh that sounds like a sound bite oh
another exciting announcement guys i am
happy to
tell you all that i am the king
undisputed king of white
people twitter yes i ethan klein
white people twitter 90 000 points
bask in the glory i am a reddit god and
i am white
depending on who you ask of course
keemstar doesn't think so
i said dear undecided voters the
republican senate just went on vacation
instead of passing a coveted relief bill
which is true by the way that is true
they've got the supreme court in the
nominee in which let's freak
let's let's i mean you know let's let's
be honest
they just they want to do that in case
trump lost even though
everybody in the country really doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that they just need
covered relief you know but they're like
nah
let's take a break yeah crazy huh
so there you have it wow
yeah well vin diesel you're rich what do
you care
talk to me baby you guys want to look at
some zach uh
tiktok hell yeah he's been up to it man
zach has been non-stop zach tell me
you probably got a lot of new followers
after our segment right
i definitely did yes [ __ ]
okay a lot of a lot of hate a lot of
love really
you've got a lot of haters a lot of
people saying the content court my ass
but you know
i had that one coming um god i'm having
fun with it
so this one is called i can't play the
music but it's just staying alive you
guys heard it
oh i love when you wink by the way it's
the worst wink i've ever seen
i have to say [ __ ] you well it's hard to
even tell
if you're winking because your eyes are
kind of
like here i almost was like did he just
wink it's hard to tell look at his eye
because it's closed so much you go oh
yeah it's not a great it's a twitch it's
a twitch more than a week i
had to break it to you
one sec so somebody's saying something i
got a vibe real quick
so what is it that somebody said to you
because you're like hold on one sec i
gotta vibe real quick
i'm just on my way out of the door to go
vibe you know
and you took your shirt off oh you're
not wearing a shirt excellent
no [ __ ] fantastic
yeah i love the winking keep doing the
wings
let's see
whoa why is it is it meant to be like
that why is it
no i don't think it's why is it
what the [ __ ] refresh it yeah there you
go
you guys know the song
do you think of yourself as a sex icon
because i kind of get the vibe
not at all i am self-aware i'm extremely
self-worth i'm trying to
make these as cringy as [ __ ] possible
oh forever
really yeah
really i don't know if i believe yeah
i love the winking though again you kind
of have the same issue where it's more
of a twitch
here i got a problem here it is here it
comes
oh that one you know what that one was
better oh wow we're not going to take
that oh
god
one more oh in the giraffes holy [ __ ]
are we going into the drafts again yeah
these are published
i don't know these aren't published yet
these aren't public these are all these
are premieres
yeah oh that's exciting they're not
published the ones we've seen so far are
right zach okay yes so this one was
just getting my 80s vibe on just as you
know i get down with some 80s
i think there's a wink in this one too
yep that one was
mtv what the glasses the shoes
80s just the glasses and the shoes and
the mtv
that's it that's all you need to vibe
got him hey i love
jeff stop it all right now we're in the
drafts these are unpublished this is
exciting
this is the real [ __ ] yeah now why
aren't these published were you trying
to premiere or were you thinking they
were too cringey to post
a little too cringy maybe i just didn't
have the balls to post them
so this is better just to premiere in
front of you know
half a million people i'd rather have
some company
to death here uh another pretty girl's
zack i'm
scared where this is going okay
i really think i'm out here trying to
take bellathorn but i'm just trying to
get a golden ticket from daddy wonka
she um she grabbed the dude's dick
nice oh my god
did she grab his dick
i really think i'm out here trying to
take down a thorn but i'm just trying to
get a gun to take it from daddy wonka
oh i don't the okay all right a little
bit
[Music]
jesus man you definitely should post
that one
if you're trying to be cringey then you
should be posting those ones not the
other ones
blue yoga's let's go these are my
favorites
zach what are we doing here okay here we
go
we meet again men of culture
[Laughter]
certified west coast kitty cat
dude i'm sorry but i [ __ ] love ass so
much zach what
is it is that even a point
also in the dark why would anyone want
to watch that
like what's the entertainment value of
that tick tock
my reaction to it because that's what
everyone's thinking
the best is last guys the best is like
like uh
you know but like that's the point of
this video
you know i'm saying to him he didn't
post it yeah
he didn't
dude i'm sorry but i [ __ ] love ass so
much
i just don't know that that's such a
good insight
[Laughter]
that people would necessarily want to
watch that that's fair that's why
or is the joke that you're just like
dude i just can't get over this ass like
there's nothing else to say
my throat i'm gertie today boy
today the best one oh boy
oh my this one's going to kill me
all right well i can't play the music
because you know but
should i play it i if the music fits it
better yeah
you're being sexy don't deny that you're
trying to affect you
why are you denying it that's clearly
what you're doing
i'm trying to mix the sexiness with the
cringiness that's my goal here
sexy cringe okay i don't think that's
what you're doing
i love it though don't let me discourage
you you should post all of these
they're all just as good i love this i
love this
oh i love when your eyes open and you're
like you don't know where to look
okay like you're trying to find the
camera but you can't it's weird
watch his eyes he's like okay do it
again
[Laughter]
the best for me was that fall back man
that was good i want to [ __ ] this guy
zach whoever he is
z lewis 97 he's on tick-tock boys that
tick tock name too
yeah yeah he's keeping it real dude he
loves that
i love house speaking of tick tock i
found some new
tick tocks in my i got to do a segment i
think every friday
where i find like because when i'm
searching
just on browsing tick tock i just i
always find the best stuff like look at
this guy
this one is the best i was just cracking
the [ __ ]
up you sent this to me i
[Music]
so all of his videos of him pouring
spice and lemon juice on people's phones
and then feeding them and then feeding
them those peanuts
yeah it's stuffed penis okay and by the
way
oh got a little got a little uh chewy
bite there huh
thumbs up yeah you know and he's turkish
too which is like
leads perfectly in with my obsession
i think this guy even tops cesium hey
yay
i don't know so like
there's just so many you know the lemon
so i feel like the spices on the phone
probably started
in by accident and then it became a meme
right like
i'm assuming at first
there's a look look at look i love how
he he
often discards the lemon like on their
food
in this case he just throws it right on
her phone
you see like but you'll see ones where
he throws it right in their dish
he looks like ron jeremy too by the way
and he's fighting that's a that's an
example of a living meme
who oh yeah took the joke and ran eat
this penis little girl oh boy
man i'm sorry yeah i can't do this
with the little kids i can't do it okay
why so many little kids come on let's
get some adults in here hey happy
birthday
that looks dangerous
did you see how he just drops the lemon
wherever the [ __ ] he finishes the juice
that is not a dessert don't eat it if
you don't want to
don't do it thank you
okay oh no phone
no phone huh just a penis i don't want
i don't want anyone feeding me let alone
a [ __ ] penis by the way
you know no look all that lemon juice
and spice
the guy's like what the [ __ ] see i don't
think i don't think everybody knows
what's happening
yeah maybe not everybody look at his
face
watch this guy he's like what the [ __ ]
this is my favorite tick tock account oh
my god
yeah i was dying i was enjoying this so
much yesterday
look at his own poster at the back and
it was in the previous one
dude that's way too much lemon oh this
he's ruining the dish he picks up the
phone
and then that's the penis yeah
yeah that would totally happen in israel
exactly
things are not so different
all right there's too many kids in here
here we go i think there's one where he
throws the lemon right on his dish watch
because you know you just saw he's
touching people's phones he's getting
around he's not
the gloves are to protect his hand not
anything else
so i just love how he dumps the lemon
what are you doing dude he's seasoning
the whole table
he's the best he's the king oh i think
this is the first one i saw where i was
dying
i was like it looked like he i didn't
understand that
this is his thing yeah
oh god it's so disgusting the penis
thing
what the [ __ ] oh the guy's like no no no
no
on the phone only that's what's up
this guy's a real fan
yeah i could watch this all day no my
phone on my phone please
yeah she's doing it herself yeah no no
no
no on the phone
[Laughter]
it's a lot of lemon juice on the phone
oh yeah i probably if
i don't think lemon juice could be good
i mean it's corrosive
all right let's see those phones boys
yeah you can see there's a lot of these
too
oh sneak attack hey
they didn't i don't know that they saw
that coming
yeah we love it so that's our boy
sir don chi minhent
on tick tock he's an undisputed king
one other tick tock before we move on
someone explain this to me please
i don't know what is going on but it's
apparently just a day in russia as they
say
can i not full screen why is it so
tick-tock sucks
it's so zoomed out here let me like do
one of these ghetto zooms
okay vladimir putin
[Music]
so go ahead and explain there's a man in
the middle of the street a horse
slams into something the dude needs [ __ ]
and then this guy just backs the [ __ ]
away
[Music]
i've never seen anything like this any
fault
[Laughter]
i never seen anything like this
i didn't you know i've never even seen
really a horse crash like that's awesome
she just eats [ __ ]
so the walk back
be careful dude and he's out
okay okay good stuff any uh
calls uh should i do music before we
move on uh
we should do our ad we're about 30
minutes in already god i really wasted a
lot of time at the top of the show
indeed indeed all right do i have it
you sure do it's in your inbox boy it is
that sure is
would you question vin let's see
we guys should be a little more
prepared you're in the meantime
ring doorbell is the ultimate
home security item there's thousands of
reasons why protecting a home matters
for me i love having the ring so i can
know what the f
is going on around my house at all times
it's got the motion detector
it's got the two-way calling it uses
wi-fi so if you're in mexico taking a
vacation
i don't recommend going to mexico right
now or anywhere really where can i
vacation
i wouldn't fly right now if you are
in or if you are taking a walk around
the block
and you get a ring notification you can
check it it goes up to the cloud and you
have it forever just in case shenanigans
go down
bring out security products for every
corner of your home inside and out and
best of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone
somebody stops by if something's going
on ring lets you know it's a piece of
mind
anytime knowing that your home is
protected
whenever you call home ring has
something you need to protect see and
speak to whoever is at your door
or anywhere with ring video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable home security system you can
easily install yourself
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ring.com
h3 it comes with ring video doorbell 3
and chime pro the perfect way to start
your ring
experience plus free two-day shipping
so go to ring.com h3 that's ring.com
h3 you know i do genuinely love the ring
i do too
i think it's the best one if you need
security it's the best one because at
our last house we had a lot of scary
issues and i installed like rings like
all over the house and
i i really genuinely could finally like
sleep easy
knowing that i had an idea what was
going on around the house
i love it ring.com h3
all right we got a lot of uh donations
hopefully maybe uh get to some of them
go ahead
uh van luke uh hold on a second
let me uh there we go oh did we want a b
nice dad
maybe nice dad to help with those yeah i
could read them if you want
yeah just keep an eye on them so that
like if something interesting
or good comes up then you can just
take a note and let us know we got a few
hundred dollar ones
oh wow go ahead what do they got to say
oh wow um
so van luke 7 said your episode with
trish and dr drew made me cry and made
me want to be friends with trish which
is something i never thought i'd say
love y'all's relationship much love
y'all thank you i have to admit that i
cried too when i watched it did you
really
i did it was very emotional yeah i
thought i thought it was really
productive you know i thought it was
really good because
because i'm not here when they recorded
so i have no idea what
what to expect when i put it on no i
think it's great because look trisha is
not
she's not what everyone thinks she is
and i think that
dr drew was great by the way yeah um i
can't wait to have did you
email him did you talk to him dan about
getting him back on uh yeah
okay great i think zach is going to fail
a personality test
because we're a londoner we can fail
like if we give like a narcissistic
or like a sociopathic test not fail but
i was trying to think who in the crew
would score high
on like a personality disorder test
i'm a sociopath no i don't think you're
a sociopath but i think you would
make i was just trying to get i just
thinking like who would who would score
high points
i don't know i'd be i'd be interested in
knowing that too
i don't think you're a sociopath though
no no no i don't think i just thought
you might you might win a couple of
points in a certain category
fair enough right
yeah i'm crazy but i don't know enough
about a b
frankly either he could be just a
full-blown psycho
it's always the quiet ones that is
you eat anybody abey have you eaten
anybody
uh no no okay i wasn't very convincing
you passed
what do you mean by eden yeah sexually
he's kind of throwing me off a little
bit have you eaten human flavor have you
eaten a human being yes or no
yeah no do you have body parts in your
fridge
what's in your freezer right now is
there several water
i have a shitload of water bottles oh
you like the frozen water good
i can verify he don't have [ __ ] in his
his fridge right now okay
um thank you for the donation anything
else
there's a box we'll read them for a
hundred dollars beaver said the homie
just got out of jail yesterday
we would love to call in we're going
through so much and make our day
and they gave their names on discord he
just got out of jail and he gave us
money
does he need the money homie just got
out of jail oh his home he just got out
of jail
okay i'll talk to his homie yeah
i'm curious about what that's like sure
i'll talk to anybody
okay um maybe you can message me or zach
right now on discord yes dma port 4.
let's talk about praising dude [ __ ] it
um we have
rox roxanne aria r-a-x-n-n for 100
thank you zac for asking the real
questions on the bell delphine episode
thank you i love using zach as a proxy
for all my perverted
questions that's my favorite zach was
wondering
[Laughter]
oh wow
dude i love goats ghosts are the best
animals
i can't believe they just made they
cruise around screaming like that
this is the best how's that not like a
person
goats are the greatest
big donations thank you guys anything
else
um this one's interesting from ben for
ten dollars he said hey guys this is all
i can donate but it's really important
to me that you guys see this have you
guys ever considered
implementing a red bell pepper into your
teddy fresh to symbolize your path in
life
no thank you though the red bell pepper
it's too much of a deep cut you know
what i mean it's like
i just don't love it visually i guess if
it was like a better looking fruit or
you know like a cherry cherry that'd be
cool the cherry
the faded cherry a red bell puffer
doesn't do it to me
yeah i guess usually the reality isn't
isn't quite as compelling as
what we had hoped to be for design
um maybe maybe if we do something with
the cherry
jesus christ pardon me if i have coffee
did you
well so you had some leftovers on the
counter and i ate your toast and eggs
but that's it i didn't have coffee
oh you know what it is i had a few
cigarettes
like over the over the week yeah marc
rubio came over yeah and we had a few
smokes a few drinks
it was fun but i think it's the
cigarettes
um i was saying maybe if we do something
with the cherry
then you all know that's what it is that
it's a code
right for a red belt but we'll tell you
we'll be like hey we made this thing
with a cherry it's supposed to be a red
bell pepper
okay this dude throws us okay this dude
throws a snake in a car
what why why did this happen
oh did he not know the car was coming
was that just cosmic flu god
so can you see this okay is this just a
cosmic fluke or is he trying to [ __ ]
with this person
you got to know what happens next
crash into a wow trough and burn
i hate snakes but snakes and spiders for
me are
are everything i hate in life
you know if you're not spooked from
spiders the same way i am are you
no i don't like them but i'm not i can't
[ __ ] with them
i can't see him i can't think about him
i'm with you on that
i [ __ ] hate spiders i'm more spoken
of cockroaches than anything
i mean i'm not as spooked cockroaches
are disgusting but i know they're
harmless so
right they're freaky but yeah i would be
less
um like i would have less of a problem
being next to something that could harm
me
than being next to a cockroach it makes
no sense well
you have a genuine cockroach phobia i
guess yeah we used to get cockroaches
in our apartment in uh israel and boy
those were long nights and those
cockroaches got in
sometimes there was a few and then the
worst is you chase them out with a
bottle of raid
and then they escape towards you they
escape but then you don't know where
they are
yeah and so you have to dig up your
whole apartment because of ela
and then it's like i just can't be
comfortable i would just be like okay
i'm just here and i can't do anything
because i don't know where it is the
worst night for us was when there was
like a whole family of
rats moved into our apartment with us
and a cockroach too and we had the we
just bailed
we're just like you know what i called
my mom yeah and i was like well you just
you got to come pick there was like a
whole family of five not i think they
were mice not rats
our apartment was so small it was
probably you know
the size of this after dark set yeah you
know
so there wasn't any space to even like
hide from that yeah
and uh that was that was a horrible
you actually became really good at
catching them with that technique that
you
yeah i devised this ridiculous thing
where i had a bucket
i got a tube you know a tube that goes
in a uh paper towel roll
yeah like the end of it yeah so you got
this cardboard tube
and then at the end you put a little
peanut butter you put it on the edge of
the counter and then the bucket under it
so they go in to get the
ketchup or the the peanut butter and
they fall in the bucket
it worked every time pretty amazing
and then we would release them somewhere
and then they would come right back
yes someone would someone got angry at
us because he's like you're releasing
outside there's gonna become someone
else's problem i was like i'm not gonna
kill him
no they were so cute actually yeah they
were tiny little
dude yeah all right
let someone else kill him
you know people feed those to their
snakes who have snack like live little
sweet little mice yeah that's thing
what'd you say i said it's disgusting
have you ever seen a video of that
no people get off and watching i mean i
understand the snakes need to eat and
all that but
i don't understand people wanting to
watch that go down to me it's very
disturbing and i understand a cycle of
life and all that [ __ ] and yes i eat
meat
i'm a [ __ ] and a hypocrite and all that
but i don't like seeing animals suffer
um i does anyone know anyone with a
snake as a pet
like i always find those people so weird
uh
i i've not you know sean my sean balog
had a snake
oh he's totally the kind of person that
would do that
i think he's a good guy though so it
doesn't mean anything bad about it no
but i agree there's something there's
something particular about people with
snacks
snakes as pets my best friend had a
snake
how did he die my friend tried to get
rid of him and try to throw him out the
window
my friend's an interesting character but
then when he was trying to throw him out
the snake started to wrap around his
hand
your mic is like way overdriven it's
what
you're like way too loud turn down your
mic oh sorry it's like clipping
casey neistat would never be in case you
wouldn't make
let's see ozzy got a tiger snake up his
pant leg
this one i saw on the internet and i i
honestly couldn't watch it because
it's so disturbing this is my worst
nightmare
and i hate everything about it and i
it's another is this a poisonous snake
yes if it's in australia it's almost
certainly oh they're like
yeah it's no it's the most poisonous
snake in the world they have poisonous
flies there
i'm taking a little while yeah how in
the [ __ ] could that even happen dude
yeah
it was [ __ ] like toys like the dogs
chased up my [ __ ] leg [ __ ] help
clamp him off with a
[ __ ] pair of vice grips what
what is going on he's got some tight
jeans on too
what yeah wish me luck what the [ __ ]
we'll see if we get this card out of you
oh my god starting to wonder that the
theory that
[ __ ] um uh [ __ ] not killing snakes
here we go one [ __ ] two
i'm glad he's okay we need him oh yeah
yeah is this a fake video because the
snake was so limp
it doesn't move at all i mean it sounds
real but like
there's no movement in that snake not
once
let's watch the part where he pulls it
out it happens so
fast
here we go one [ __ ] two
it doesn't like respond to his touch i
don't know
thoughts does anyone else think maybe it
could be fake
i i don't know i mean maybe the fear in
his voice sounds very
real to me i agree yeah if it's fake
he's a great actor they're saying a fake
oh they're all saying it's fake
i mean some the the chat saying that
yeah the chat is saying they think it's
fake
the thing is they never show the snake
moving
you know that makes me suspicious maybe
it's hibernating
can we bring sean on the podcast sean
get him a call back in sure that would
be fun yeah
a dog this guy breaks up a fight between
a cat and a dog either
uh-oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] dude this cat is out of
his mind
bro oh my god
that poor dog he didn't deserve that i
gotta watch that again
i gotta watch that one more time
this guy is just trying to protect his
poor doggy
dude this cat is not stopping oh my god
it's true what they say about cats and
dogs huh
i love that his butt is so loud he loves
his dog man
that was insane
holy [ __ ] they are mortal enemies as
they say you know
wow it's almost always the dog chasing
the cat though i've never seen a cat go
at a dog i feel like the cat is always
the douche to the dog
no someone said i messaged zach i
accidentally cut my leg with a chainsaw
when i was 16.
send pics oh that sounds gnarly
zach you see the pics and report back i
don't have a message from the person
that's really bad with gore
i don't know if you want to exactly send
it to a bee
doesn't have the stomach for it another
snake one you guys really [ __ ] with
me this week huh
that there was a ton of snake videos
what's going on here what is happening
yeah
oh [ __ ] another snake in the shirt dude
can you guys
how how does that happen oh
oh no bro i refuse to believe these are
real
how does a snake get down somewhere this
guy looks legit scared i think this one
is real
why is there a fake heartbeat in the
video why is there a fake
video
it's like a whole genre right now faking
snake videos
i feel like that's what's what's
happening
it's not moving it looks kind of fake
i'm not gonna even lie look at the
bottom of it
let's see if it moves
why do people get a fake [ __ ]
let's see i mean i'm tense even thinking
did it move or did it just oh it's
moving
bro how does this happen though what did
he fall asleep or something i mean
there's no other way yeah
it's gone
i would not be able to stay calm like
that dude holy [ __ ]
yeah i think most people would just
stand up and start freaking out i mean
it could be a pet snake
in which case there's no danger but he
seems scared
like he seems really worried why is
there a heartbeat
why is there a heartbeat
that's a tiny little snake it's his back
it's nice
[Music]
you can do that on anything really
so this person just sent me the chainsaw
pics we cannot show this
yeah it's gnarly as [ __ ] yeah i didn't
think so
what happened like how does that happen
i'm scared of chainsaws for that reason
it's like yeah oh it's like
hey i'm just sawing the thing oops
my arm's gone [ __ ] that
um how about alligators how do you feel
about alligators
i love them you do did you swim with
them
i probably wouldn't no probably
rhett from good mythical morning is
really getting up there with the risks
and challenges
what did you think was gonna happen man
he was so happy he's like hey i got this
dude he was so close to dying he's like
nah i'm not into it the crocodile
yeah he would have killed you so easy
so easy i can't believe how cool they
look it's just like not real
yeah they're like little dinosaurs
really yeah
okay here's the a bird flying into a
paraglider takes them both down but both
survive so fear
wow let's see i've got some scoops here
that i wanted to talk about in my
basement
right
how are you doing this week hila um
i don't know i've been feeling really
exhausted all week
really me too theodore's been having
trouble sleeping he's been doing better
but i'm just been tired man
um what do you think you've been feeling
exhausted just working a lot
i'm not sure i think so but i don't know
it just uh maybe it's just the end of
the year there's always like so much
yeah with teddy fresh there's a lot
leading up to the end of the year
there's a lot going on and we've got the
offices with the new offices that we're
working on which
is exciting but it's just a lot of
stress hey did you hear i've been
meaning to talk about this for a while
jeffrey tubin who is a
he's a this guy what's who is tuban he
was a like
a journalist oh he's just a journalist
yeah he is cnn's chief legal analyst
and a renowned reporter for the new
yorker he's been sidelined
at a pivotal moment in the run-up
presidential election the reason he
exposed himself
during a zoom call he went to beat off
this old dude is still being not oh
that's saving them
wow so they're having a zoom meeting and
somebody apparently recorded it was like
yo i'm gonna put this on youtube
which is pretty cool for us i had a beat
off
right this isn't explicit is it
it's on youtube so probably not no it's
good
okay can i actually
pop out this call since i'm not on this
account
stop off okay guys sean hey joey on
wait why is it why is his face like yeah
why is there a thing over his face
yeah they covered his face with a
picture of himself why
um i'm not sure but this is the best
video i could find
why the [ __ ] would they do that that's
just that's weird bizarre
okay can i actually pop out this call
since i'm not on this account okay
guys so he turned off the camera but
then it came back on he enters with
lube oh and napkins wow
next to the camera camera by the way
this girl sees what's going on she's
like i see the bottle of lube
all right let's not go here sofia knows
sophie is trying to
starting to help you jeff jeff don't do
it
if you look uh don't do it jeff higher
than 2009
sophia sees what's happening
oh oh my god dude the bottom left was
like oh no
yeah all the reactions are pretty cool
this is real this is like a comedy
sketch yeah like look at all the faces i
mean this is
this is unbelievable the way that he's
got like the lotion in the shot it's so
are you sure this is real terms i know
what happened but is this really the
footage
yeah i i went through and like yeah this
is this is the same screenshot i kept
seeing
of all these co-workers holy [ __ ] this
is amazing look how
disgusted she is in the bottom right
hand how do we find this sheet off wow
everybody's saying that this is not it
i'm pretty sure this isn't real
because this footage was not released
dude this was this is not public
that's why his face is covered you got
you got duped my dude
i got duped you guys come on look at
his face covered with a little picture
of him this is all a [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is a farce that's right all right
well
is there are these real people amy
what's happening here give me the give
me the
story this is probably another incident
where somebody did something similar and
they
and they pasted this dude's face over it
all the yeah but like
the articles i was reading on it they
had a screenshot of these people
show me maybe it's real let's do the
research let's find out let's get to the
bottom of this
like my biggest fear well just don't
beat off when you're on a zoom call
like if it's your biggest fear don't do
that why would you do that on it
just don't like cover your cam if you're
paranoid for another round
24 hours in a day yeah i mean to do it
or something just don't do it right in
that exact spot if you're paranoid you
know what i mean
like there's no way if i was like i have
to beat off right
now i would not do it there or i would
turn off the camera
i would restart my computer for [ __ ]
sake you know what i mean there's no
chance you don't take chances
look at me i had a beat off i'm
surprised the dude of his age is so
eager to just
beat off like in the middle of the day
i can't remember the last time i beat
off in the middle of the day that's some
like
you never you never go for the nooner
well back when i was
back when i was younger maybe had more
free time
and had more desire maybe too i don't
know back in the day you know you have
nothing to do you're playing world of
warcraft i get beat off 11 times in a
day don't get me wrong
eleven times g sure sometimes
you know
zack what's the most you've beat off in
a day uh
my record is eight and you took track
you actually did the inventory i had a
friend that
jerked off 22 times in a span of 24
hours that's like
basically all you're doing all day oh
that's what he did yeah
he said his last load like nothing came
out and it was just pain
it was nothing but pain sounds fun it
sounds like
oh so wait ela what is this is this it
i'm trying to figure it out
well i would like to know the answer to
this
because here's a video that ela found
look look into this uh look into it aby
yeah yeah
i need a definitive answer on this one i
mean i agree it does it does look
great but like as i'm going through the
articles some people are using
like that screenshot but it's not it's
not saying that that's actually it like
another article just had a
picture of a zoom tutorial um
yeah i'm looking let's see a spokesman
for cnn says
jeff has asked for some time off while
he deals with a personal
issue what do you mean a personal issue
he was caught jacking off
we know what they
an upcoming event relating to tuban's
recent book about trump was also
postponed
oh man he's he's going to miss that i
made an embarrassing stupid
mistake believing i was off camera oh i
would like to apologize to my wife
family friends and co-workers holy [ __ ]
so embarrassing dad what happened i was
caught beating off on zoom
in front of all my co-workers nice
but like even in that video by the way
even in that video
which i'm presuming is fake because when
you're sitting on zoom you can't see my
dick you can't see my crotch which leads
me to believe that he was like
you know what i mean like i don't care
but if someone is doing this motion
or you know but then you can know
[Music]
i agree but apparently he showed it
according to the report i mean either
way it's inappropriate
oh yes so i don't know if that's what
they mean
very inappropriate in fact keemstar what
are you doing
what i can't worship that video is a
pornhub ad it's
it's definitely fake what are you doing
keemstar this is not appropriate
but that's not appropriate keemstar wow
oh wow
not appropriate knock it off very
hypocritical get out of here abe you
gotta
you can't begin
yeah i apologize everyone and thank you
everyone for sending me the same exact
video
right now everyone sending me the same
video
what video is that the one the one we
just watched the pornhub
the actual one i don't think there is no
actual one i'm telling you the answer
it's a pornhub
yeah i know that one is i'm saying his
colleague his colleagues aren't gonna
upload it to youtube dude yeah
although that'd be well i guess that'd
be pretty fun i mean i was pretty
surprised you could tell from the
beginning i was like wow there's video
of this
it's pretty insane all righty
can we play this zach got him play what
zack saying got him got him oh play that
go ahead zach
wait where's the kim kardashian story
ian got him
i wanted to talk about kim kardashian
but i don't see it here
which her uh private island [ __ ]
yeah
her um really humble birthday isn't
supposed to be in here
very humbled it's under uh topical
stories
oh i feel like we're not getting enough
ian in the
show yeah ian's yeah i see it okay
well he's been good in the content
course but yeah he's hiding out a little
bit too much for sure
okay kim kardashian she i don't know if
you guys saw this
but she goes she's very relatable you
know having her 40th birthday like you
do
these are ideas for you by the way
either in five years when i turn 40
40 feeling so humbled
humbled is just not the right word
feeling so humbled and blessed there is
not a single day that i take for granted
okay but then she continues ready it's
like okay cool friends and family
for my birthday this year i couldn't
think of a better way to spend it than
with the people that have helped shape
me to who i am
okay before kovit i don't think any of
us truly appreciated what a simple
luxury it was
to be able to travel and be together
okay right after two weeks
this is when it gets wild after two
weeks of multiple health
screens and asking everyone to
quarantine i surprised my closest
inner circle how many people have inner
circles
you know i got outer circles and inner
circles
i surprised my closest inner circle with
a prime with a trip to a private island
where we could pretend things were
normal for just a brief moment in time
wow this one is like okay well what it's
normal hey guys
it's normal you did what why are you
telling us
we danced rode bikes swam near wales
kayaked watched a movie on the beach and
so much more
i just want you guys to know how [ __ ]
more empathetic your life is
the best sentence i realized that for
most people
this is something that is so far out of
reach right now
right now ever so in moments like these
i'm humbly reminded of how privileged my
life is
wow she's like trying to be like
appealed to the people
humble brag that's not a humble brag
that's a [ __ ]
it wasn't in my basement
and meanwhile you got the quartering
over here being in his basement talking
about a tale of two cities
i just peed in my basement i can't even
believe this post
where to begin i just don't even
understand you know what if the
quartering was within kim kardashian's
inner circle
he would probably still be he would find
a basement somewhere on that island
and not come out of it and he would say
my wife went out for pizza without me
uh it's [ __ ] awesome yeah i hate her
actually this made me happy could you be
so self-centered like dude if you're
gonna go have that party just
like don't it's all pictures of look how
great we look here
she probably did fittings for like six
months for this dress
with a whole crew you know it's like
okay i don't know what to tell you
you really didn't need to share this
especially you need to share it that's
during this time exactly okay you're a
trillionaire i get it go do your private
island with all your friends and stuff
but don't come up here and try to act
all humble and [ __ ] don't even mention
the word humble
really like don't even mention she
missed that word
she brought it up right now yeah she
brought it up a lot
got him i didn't even know you could do
things like that
right that com i mean this must have
cost like 10 million dollars this trip
i don't even know maybe more yeah yeah
the the net worth over this whole family
is like
so in don't even know what what are your
thoughts on this because you obviously
are a fan of the family
did you find this to be a bit much
i mean i don't really see the problem
personally i would love to go to an
island
yeah like she's helping the local
tourist
economy that's true
well here's where it gets weirder that's
a good point so it's a private island
bro somebody's gotta work
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] weird you guys
okay all right oh [ __ ] k
it's crazy they're so rich that like
what do you do for a birthday gift you
know i'm gonna bring you guys
just buy something i'm gonna bring your
dead dad back to life yeah
this is the weirdest gift ever and i
can't say that i would necessarily even
think it's a good gift but she's
crazy enough to think it's great for my
birthday kanye
kanye got me the most thoughtful gift of
a lifetime
a special surprise from heaven a
hologram
of my dad it is so lifelike we watch it
over and over
filled with emotion so like i'm not sure
i would want someone to reanimate my
dead
parent you know what i mean because his
family is [ __ ] deranged because
it's not your dad it's not your dad yeah
this
family really so watch this [ __ ] it's
truly it's like a scene out of the
haunted mansion you know they've got
those holograms
like i would love to see him just in the
hot tomatoes hi kim
happy 40th birthday so proud of you
you're like
oh [ __ ] i ain't your daddy i wonder if
she secretly didn't like it it's like
kind of a lame gift too it's like
well at that level of wealth there's
nothing he can buy her you know
yeah so you have to like go
beyond anything like yeah he probably i
mean
he probably spent i don't know how much
you spent on this a lot people make all
the games probably started a whole
corporation hired an engineering team
yeah yeah it's like we gotta
revolutionize the holograms
for kim for her birthday
i'm gonna hire the best tech people out
there does she know about cameras
let's watch this you're 40 and all grown
up you look
beautiful just like when you were a
little girl so by the way that doesn't
make me feel good like if i saw
my dad like that i don't know how i
would feel it's not i
in my opinion it's disturbing the thing
is it's not your dad
it's not it's an actor whose face has
been like
words in his mouth and then kanye put
words in his mouth
you're 40 and you still look good it's
like are you calling me old
and he said he says there's one part
where he goes you marry kanye the
greatest here you'll hear
i watch over you and your sisters and
brother and the kids
every day sometimes i drop yeah but
but that's not your dad right that's not
him
that's not real like when you hear
someone
like maybe it'd be better to reanimate a
favorite moment
something that really happened so you
could be like oh relive that moment
but none of this is real he's not real
it's an actor kanye wrote this
not kanye he probably hired the best
korean writer out
in hollywood he just he added that line
where he's like yeah there's our
this is like writer's room okay here i'm
going to play it
make a big peepee remember when i would
drive you to school on my tiny mercedes
every day
we would listen to this song together
he licensed this for a billion dollars
i'm skipping this because obviously
so proud of the woman that you've become
kimberly and all that you've
accomplished
all of your hard work and all the
businesses you have built are incredible
but most impressive is your commitment
to become a lawyer
and carry on my legacy is a long and a
hard road
but it's worth it and i'm with you every
step of the way
the way that you're connecting with your
roots and supporting armenia means so
much to me
you are a proud armenian
father the most beautiful thing that i
have witnessed
is watching you grow your family
you married the most most most
most genius man in the whole world holy
[ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] psychotic and by the way
jesus christ not really it's not i mean
nobody there's no laughter nothing about
this feels personal too it almost feels
like it was just made like as a
pr statement to put out there he
kanye the way you connected with your
armenian roots
amazing yeah all the work you do out
there for armenian people so impressed
with you kimberly
you know but can you imagine kanye west
reanimated her dead
dad to firm to say this i have witnessed
is watching you
grow your family you married
the most most it's like your dad wants
to [ __ ] on you
whole world
oh yeah i'm sure dad would say that yeah
most most most most
just like dad used to talk about my
boyfriends
are the most most why would this even be
shared with us
why would they even put that out why
would this even be out if it was such a
personal
message we can't keep anything private
yeah beautiful soul
know that i am very proud of you and i'm
always with you
i have built a firewall around our
family
i love you kimberly tell courtney chloe
and rob i love them
and miss you all well kim the most
and kanye ellen say what up to kanye oh
turned into water you know be cool if it
like if it turned into like a skeleton
like the [ __ ] dude in indiana jones
he just like dies all of a sudden
it's just like a skeleton and don't look
at it
i found this article uh about it and
though there is not exactly the price
robert kardashian one cost
the tupac one at coachella cost 10
million
yeah so yeah that's what i was like dude
people invest in this for
world tours not for a birthday party
i think uh i mean the tupac thing was a
while ago it's probably come down
a decent amount because they they do it
semi-regularly now but
yeah it's a lot of money not sure not if
kim and kanye are involved yeah probably
not
they would raise it up thanos got him
says somebody in the chat
dan has done he got snapped
i think it's pretty lit to be honest
yeah how lit is it i'm gonna have to buy
a hologram for you i don't know what
don't reanimate for aien but
how late on like uh like california on
fire or
or just malibu on fire
how lit campfire doing wildfire
i mean reducing the human experience a
living soul
down to you know learning algorithms
code that's my ideal world to be honest
right that's a good point right
one one step closer to robot utopia
oh hey guys i'm a psychic medium who
would
no love to read for you guys bring a man
i also was recently diagnosed with
parkinson's disease
that's a sad twist that's a sad twist
but i'm down to get a medium reading but
i don't believe in this stuff and i
think that
will probably not be fun for anybody
because i'll just be so skeptical that
it'll just be coming off as a dick you
know yeah
especially if the person is sick yeah
um
meanwhile in russia you know it's good
another russia it's always in russia my
god
vladimir putin
what the [ __ ]
vladimir
[Music]
that's what they meant to do
[Music]
i love how casual the rescue operation
is it's just like a dude
with the camera yeah
he's in a normal clothing he doesn't
have a life vest on or anything
that's how they do it in my homeland
diesel uh well damn right i forgot i'm
vin diesel right now
i was like wait you're from russia dan
not today death not today
for the [ __ ] dingo huh
these videos are so upsetting to me why
couldn't you just wait you're water
why couldn't you just wait look how
close to death she is
oh my god just wait god damn it
whoa why would you attempt a train you
got him
thank you zach oh this is this is a
pretty wild one he's
fine let me just preface this because i
watched this it looks like he dies but
he doesn't he's totally fine
so homie with the truck
dude get out of the way
yeah he's fine he is he's fine how is he
fine
he is there he is you get that he got up
wow wouldn't you be like i got a piece
out once this
truck like get out get out move move
is he stuck what the hell now i don't
know anything about repairing cars but i
think
probably hanging lifting your feet up
and hanging like that
maybe not a good call on the other hand
probably not that stable of a platform
either
who's at fault the platformer the manual
what did he try to do
yeah i don't know anything about cars
like i said but that doesn't look like
an official
move he's like let's go
and i'm dead i don't think that's a good
to do
i think the platform is fine probably
his fault interesting
just my guess might be based on wow way
to blame the victim either yeah sorry
yeah dead
we got any calls or anything let's get
some calls going
who do we got to call him let's go how
do you call her in the
queue actually
oh the the baby bom dom thing
yes let's go here let me watch this okay
let me see we have a call
from uh uh natalie
um the person commented again i have
been to multiple locations and done
readings with some of the most haunted
artifacts i would love to give you guys
a reading before my arms
okay to get one oh she wants to come in
and meet us in person would it be in
person
yeah reach out to this i actually did a
reading with this person
um say what yeah it blew my mind
zach what are you doing behind the
scenes and not telling you
you went and had a physical reading with
this person no no no over uh discord
really and she she nailed you she said
stuff that was true about you
not necessarily about me but about a
person that i recently lost
bring her in let's do this man yeah okay
let's do it
but i don't wanna okay i'm just i don't
wanna embarrass her
because i'm so skeptical well i think we
made it clear
i made it clear she still existed so but
i'll i'm going to be
open-minded as i possibly can yeah
okay but um yeah bring it but let's do
that you want to do the the
the baby dominator yeah
[Music]
oh that was a cop wow what the [ __ ]
what am i watching what a cop
rolls hits him off the street
and there's just a hell of a collision
here a cop just
[Music]
ain't never seen it like that that's
michael bay dude yeah
you guys ready for natalie okay natalie
yes
she is in the call
natalie 24 years old are you with us
yep hello natalie thank you for joining
us so
correct me if this is all right you
found out your boyfriend was secretly
an adult baby diaper lover
he promised he never used them and that
he just
wore diapers to masturbate in okay you
better explain this
is what he told me are you still with
him
he broke up two years ago okay so so
okay
first of all how long were you dating
before you found out he
had this fetish we were dating for about
two months and we were like having
regular sex
but he couldn't come from it
and i asked him why i asked him if there
was anything that i could do
and then he like asked me to do this
sort of stuff
so what did he ask you what did he ask
you to do
um he asked for me to put the diaper on
him
um i also
so he goes okay i'm glad you asked
here's a diaper put it on me
um he i had kind of been a dom
already and like telling him stuff like
oh you're so bad you're a bad boy kind
of stuff and he said he wanted
more of that but with him wearing
something
and that's when he revealed it and okay
so but tell tell me
did he have the diaper ready he brought
out the diaper like on the spot like
tell me about what happened
yeah he hit it in a drawer like uh
in his room yeah he had it hidden and he
brought it out
and did you put the diaper on him
yeah he wanted me to put it on like
exactly like you would a baby so he like
puts his legs up in the air
and then i like scoot it under him
um he had baby powder that he pulled out
and i had to baby powder him
um and then i just wrapped him up
like nice and tight but how was it how
was it
sexual because it seems like you covered
him up yeah
so uh after i covered him up i would
just talk to him i'd say oh you're
disgusting like you're nasty
why would you speak to your baby like
that
just what he wanted um
and then he would like he would rub
himself
through the diaper he'd like squeeze his
dick really hard and start rubbing on it
um and then it would take
maybe 15 to 20 minutes and
then he would just like come oh
wow it was more like he was just
mastered you guys never had sex
like this or i mean i um
we did like once but it was really weird
i didn't want to do it again he like cut
a hole in the diaper
and i i couldn't do it again
because did you feel like you were
[ __ ] a baby kind of yeah dude
um i didn't really feel like i didn't
really feel like i was [ __ ] a baby
like he was still my boyfriend
it felt like there was just some weird
plastic
in between uh
yeah you were up for it it just wasn't
it didn't feel
good yeah and then the baby powder
was like really dry and i didn't want
that in my vagina
sure yeah yeah so
it just was not a good time i didn't do
it again i said i i'll talk to you we
we would have like regular sex and that
would be his warm-up
and then he'd get the diaper and do that
stuff now what was your first
impression when he broke all this to you
um i was super weirded out i didn't
really want to do it at first
um but i wanted to be open-minded and
just like try things i'm kind of like
zach
like i'll try things that's good good
for you it's a good way to be
but it sounds like it escalated to the
point where you were finding dirty
diapers he was [ __ ] himself in
diapers is that right
um not quite uh basically what happened
was
he escalated things where he was buying
more things so he started wearing a
pacifier
he started wearing like these onesies
and stuff and i was getting a little bit
weirded out because it was getting into
our normal life
so let me get this straight you guys
would be like chilling and he'd just put
a pacifier in his mouth
yes oh boy and would you be like dude
you gotta let's let's have some
boundaries there
yeah i was trying to have that sort of
thing but then he would like kind of
guilt me and say oh well you don't like
actually like it or something you know
wow this guy wants to just
live as a baby but so was he [ __ ]
yeah because here it says he had soiled
diapers so was he [ __ ] in the diaper
um he was not [ __ ] in the diapers
but
like from my perspective nothing was
happening in the diapers but he went on
vacation to japan
and then um i had to use his
washer and dryer so i went in to use the
washer and dryer and i went to his
closet and i thought i would just do
some laundry for him like in return
um and i found this backpack in his
closet that he was hiding
and i opened it and it was just like 40
uh
peed in diapers like sitting in there
why would he say what got him i don't
know he's
yeah that's what i i was like why would
you say that that's disgusting and it
was in a backpack that like
you would use like reuse and stuff um
what did he say yeah yeah so i asked him
i was like what is wrong with why would
you do that
so we were living or he was living with
roommates he had like three different
roommates um and he didn't want them
finding out
so he didn't want to just throw them
away he said that he just like
stored them so that he could throw them
all away at the same time
yeah that sounds good
so i guess it's so tough like that
sounds so extreme you have to find
someone who is also into that
yes yeah yeah that's a lifestyle like
100 he's looking for a straight-up mommy
uh but did you ever ask him like how did
you get into this dude like what does
this say about a person who
wants to wear a diaper and come in his
diaper i mean like does this
does did you ever wonder like what is
really going on here
maybe it's fine yeah i
did he definitely has some weird stuff
going on
he also has a twin and there was one
point where he wanted me to call him by
his twin's name
oh boy and i wouldn't do it yeah
that is weird the twin thing is wild
well did you ever wonder if maybe the
twin
snuck in and you [ __ ] the twin without
knowing
no they they weren't identical at all
wow he wanted you to call his brother's
name
and so how did it end yeah so was the
whole thing just a deal breaker like you
not being
so into this stuff yeah
basically so i was i attempted to break
up with him
um and i was still hanging
around with his roommates because we
were all friends
um and then like the day after he like
got
drunk and then like attacked me and
uh so now i have a restraining order
against him holy crap
he said he said that he like blacked out
and he was worried i was going to tell
his roommates about it
and i wouldn't keep the secret and
that's why i did it
what kind of guy is he like normally
like would people
is he like a really weird dude overtly
or was were you kind of
you know what i mean like is he like
some kind of weird alpha male then he
puts on a diaper in the bedroom
i don't think so like i wouldn't have
stayed with him if
he was uh like this weird dude or like
alpha male kind of dude
he was totally normal he's like a gamer
guy
um he just like sits in his room plays
games and goes to college he's like
totally normal
he's really good looking he has really
nice muscles
um he like he's a wrestler on our
college team
oh so he's like athletic but not like
not like uh alpha male kind of person
okay
handsome guy you probably stuck you
stuck through it for the good looks the
muscles but the diapers got the best for
you
yeah yeah otherwise that's why you gotta
date ugly dudes
i'm just gonna tell you right now you
gotta date ugly dudes natalie
are you you probably you know
yeah you gotta date fat ugly dudes those
are the best guys in the world trust me
i'm dating someone who's awesome and
really sweet and good looking so i'm
happy
i gotta say he's fit you're saying
does he [ __ ] himself yeah does he has
does he regularly put himself
oh okay no no that's okay
it sounds like you found a great guy
yeah yeah
if you stay he'll get fat eventually you
know what i mean
[Laughter]
okay don't get there well natalie thank
you for sharing your story with us
that was fantastic i mean it really was
i appreciate your
your candor fantastic thank you so much
and congratulations on uh
being with a man who's got it all right
thank you
do you have any weird fetishes oh no we
have
pretty normal sex yeah
do you ever miss the day at diaper days
absolutely not
i'm so happy now okay well we're happy
for you natalie thank you very much
thank you thank you that was great i
love that story
she's great real quick uh
we had a 50 donation from rebecca can i
get a shout out to my boyfriend
chris he's a long time fupa trooper and
super fan and his birthday is on monday
oh and they want to buy him a shout out
as a part of his present
chris chris chris chris chris chris
birthday chris chris chris i hope you're
voting cause the elections on tuesday
chris
chris chris chris chris happy birthday
chris your birthday oh and thank i just
want to say thank you to all the members
you know you guys make this all
possible this is the friday show we're
out here
out here thanks to the members it's all
out here all because of the members
thank you guys
thank you thank you with peace and love
this show will end without the members
please do not write us with peace and
love
oh man i feel you know for a guy who's
got such a weird fetish like
it's got to be tough on one hand you
know
if he's just he's got to do it right i
mean you wouldn't you wouldn't choose to
have such a [ __ ] weird fetish
he's obviously embarrassed right he's
like don't tell anybody he's hiding
diapers in his closet
yeah there's a girl out there for him
natalie just wasn't i think so
someone like belle delphine there you go
or on the
like opposite spectrum because i've seen
on tlc where they have like these
extreme
dom relationships one of like that dude
wants to sleep in a crib you know what i
mean
exactly yeah thank you on tlc
whenever i see that on my tlc i was
always wondering is this sexual i can't
tell but it sounds like it is
he just beats off in his diaper though
that's kind of boring narlier the better
that was belle oh by the way you guys
all watch belle delphine interview isn't
she great
oh she we already have a segment planned
for her she says she's going to pee in
the shower and report back
she said zach no way
no this is news to me man oh my god
why didn't you what is that this isn't a
sexual thing zach she's just peeing in
the shower
any anything involving her my heart
drops
so that just the thought of her peeing
in the shower gets you
ready it gets you excited it gets me a
whole kind of different excited man
bro you gotta chill the [ __ ]
you gotta chill the [ __ ] out dude zach
why did your voice always get lower when
you're talking
i'm bringing out my inner vin diesel i
guess so
anyway she said uh that she'll pee in
the shower and she'll come back call
into the podcast and report on it so
that's exactly wow it's not a sexual
zack
it's really not i pee in my basement
what was that that's her saying it
because
oh i'd be in my basement yeah i love
that she's a fan of the show
[Music]
i don't want to ask about her money
situation but she must be so rich from
all
she's gotta be one of the top accounts
and only fans and i know what trisha
makes she told me
yeah it's probably similar it's probably
more
or more what didn't trisha say she was
she's really big on
oh she doesn't say how much she makes
but it's a lot she told me and
my jaw dropped it's insane yeah um
trish is like top point one i mean she's
the top zero point one
right so yeah but i think i think i
think bell might be number one on the
whole website i mean she
is a tour de force we googled who the
top person was and it wasn't her but
wait dude give me a google search i'm
really curious who's the top only fans
top only fans
it was somebody i'd never heard of
before shia
him a video like a another premium video
in her dms and she charged 20
for this video of her fingering herself
and like dildoing herself
belle yeah i thought she didn't show
like that graphic stuff
yeah this was [ __ ] graphic did you
buy it of course
you think oh my god wait so she showed
her vagina because i thought she doesn't
do that she
she didn't show an actual picture of her
vagina
but you do see her fingering herself
how do you see that without her does she
like cover it
it's the angles you don't see like the
lips and all that you just see you're
you know doing it yeah exactly
zack you are [ __ ] sick dude
you dropped 20 bucks on that damn you
are a sim
research purposes two or three research
you ain't charging that to our company
are you
no no no no because sometimes we buy
zach you know
only fans for research like doctor uh
what was doctor dr jason dr jason
doesn't finger anything
dr jason oh my god zach are you wasting
all your money on porn
no no i'm not still live with your
parents man we got to get you out of
there
i know man it's about time
oh it's really about time this was uh
in september of this year somebody named
gem wolfy
is the most subscribed account on only
fans really
so where's bell on that influencer i've
never heard of her but i'm going to look
i just want to see what she looks like
influencer from australia jim wolfie gem
holy [ __ ]
gem with the j is bell on there um is
trisha on there
no their list says gem and the number
two is bella thorne
why why this is her belly
oh bella thorne right she actually is
doing cancel that [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] seems like super well
then andrea
this is vastly this is gem
gem wolf she's kind of like
um okay not what i would expect but
she's kind of thick yeah she's thick i
don't want to say that but she's like on
the she's like thick
she's known for being thick yeah she
talks how do you know ab how do you know
that
i follow i've been following her for a
long time oh have you now okay so now
there's already
on instagram i'm not paying for it sure
well apparently she's really famous i
never heard of her but like if you have
one on all my fans she must be huge
wait you really don't see belle or
trisha and on that list no no
how many people are on that list i think
it's the top five
oh jennifer bell andrea
the amount that trisha told me she makes
is
draw dropping dropping
fraud dropping like i don't think you
guys would even guess
you're dropping so and so yeah the money
is insane and it's good for them you
know i'm happy for them
i think belle made a really good point
about only fan she's like it's safe
place it's not going anywhere yeah this
is what it is
and i think that's fantastic yeah oh
yeah it is
you need to have some creepy dude
in the room with you necessarily you
mean if you're doing it just porn
if you're what do you mean by that like
um like going
to record porn somewhere oh there's no
yeah yeah yeah just kind of like it's in
your own terms
dude these girls these girls like look
at uh
these girls will go and do porn for all
these people and these guys get rich as
[ __ ] exactly
and then and these girls make like not
that much money and now these girls are
multi-millionaires
doing their own thing and it's [ __ ]
awesome [ __ ] the middle man dude forever
that's why i don't work with any
middleman here either dude
agents managers lawyers [ __ ] you i'm a
lawyer
no i'm not
but the porn industry was is is
particularly predatory
you know so i think it's great i really
do think it's great these girls are
making their own dough um
so we have another call from this
psychic is she lined up
uh yes let me pull her in right now
okay here we go guys my first psychic
reading get excited
here we go i'm i'm a little excited i've
never done this but i just
i know that it's not going to work out
for her
but i'm going to be open-minded i'm
going to be open-minded
he is on the call zach when you buy a 20
bell delphine video how many times do
you can you
use that before you get bored of it
[Laughter]
with bell never really
see me like maybe three times and i'm
like 20 bucks i mean i don't know
i think it's just more the interest
aspect of it for me
um yeah what is it seeing
seeing more of her i mean because who
doesn't want to see belle do that right
all right i can't be alone here well no
you're clearly not alone but
all right who we got on the phone with
us we have
her name is young christ
yes discord name young christ
yeah we can hear you what's your real
name my name is brooke
brooke why are you young christ
um i'm a very spiritual person and um
i used to think that listening to a
music group
that had a very similar like one of the
guys had a similar name
i thought that like if i tried that name
i would be the cool one
you know but it didn't really get me
that far and it ended up just
making a lot of people angry yeah i was
wondering about that
but here we are yeah so you believe that
you
have a psychic connection to the the
ghost realm
i do um i as um
you might know i was actually recently
diagnosed with parkinson's but before
that
um it i mean you know i've lived
my life but you know i'm also a
near-death experience so besides that
um so it's
it's hard to explain really but um
i've been to um the omen house which in
case you're not familiar
it's the place where sharon tate was
murdered by
charles manson's family
and i've done multiple readings for
people there i've done multiple
paranormal investigations going to
zac bagan's um haunted artifacts museum
in las vegas nevada
so you've got credentials you are an
experienced uh
communicator with with ghosts how old
are you
i'm 23 years old wow that's really early
to get parking yeah isn't it
it's not usually yeah it usually does
and that's kind of why i was surprised
but um i noticed
when will not notice but i actually went
to go get checked after
logic came on to your podcast
because i noticed that i i would do the
shakes
and then i was like i don't know what
this is and it kept getting worse and
worse and so
i finally went in and i got my test
results back and
it's early onset parkinson's wow
but i mean they said that how do they
how do they know for sure that that's
what it is
it's a blood test a series of like
bone marrow it's like it's a lot of
stuff
that goes into it like they've had they
did not want to give me that diagnosis
whatsoever they were like
unless you have it we don't want to say
that because we don't want to scare you
they're like
i would much rather tell you that it's
just
nerves or something but you know
after doing test after test and it was
like about three or four weeks of being
poked and prodded at and then
x-rayed and mris cat scans all that kind
of stuff
and um experimental treatments other
than
what they do for parkinson's just to see
if it stopped
um but it never did
and my mom i should i mean i
had um early signs but um
it's a very weird thing i never thought
that
i'd be in this position but
um you know life has a way of
working in mysterious ways
do you um
is your mom psychic is she sensitive is
that something that runs in the family
it can um i was raised actually
in a very religious household i was
adopted very young
so um but i i do know my biological
family
so what i remember is like they would
always
we were a mixed race family so i have
el salvadorian roots as well
so there was a lot of talk about like
bruharia and all that stuff
but usually my dad would freak out if
anybody talked about that because you
know roman catholic
no you know right but
my mom on my birth side she always knew
that
i had something there
because i would have what she thought
in what i thought were imaginary friends
when i was younger but
it like there's some things
that have happened to me in my life that
i my mom's a skeptic my adopted mom
that she can't even explain that i've
told her that
it's weird so so tell me
if you want to give us a reading so how
do we do this i actually already drew
the cards for you oh we've already
so who are we doing me or ela um so i
did
it's basically i called out
to my guides and i asked them
but who have it resonate but then i
asked um
for a specific reading for
either one of you who's resonating
um right now there's a strong
resignation for gila oh
and it's don't be scared don't worry
um but i just wanted to start out by
saying for
gila at least i pulled the six of wands
which is basically
victory so you've received recognition
and something that you've always wanted
to do
and it's you know
can i can i make you successful i want
to interject that you're obviously very
familiar with us
i'm i actually you said you were
watching the logic episode
yeah mention the logic episode
i know but i'm i'm going into this
completely un
unbiased and i'm trying to give it my
best to not
tie in anything so this is dry this is
drawn through cards
you flip a card yeah tarot cards
terrible and i pulled all of these out
at random
and so how is it that of tarot
because the cart the cards don't ex
what's the okay go ahead do ella's
reading
go ahead victory success
um and basically fine-tuning something
so there's something that i feel like
not necessarily you feel that you are
lacking in but something that you want
to
be able to get better at in
terms of i think it's more like a
personal thing it's not like a
business thing so like in the arts
and then the second one is the nine of
swords which is basically
question your fears like what is scaring
you
and think about everything that's come
up in your dreams like
if you've been having nightmares about
i'm having nightmares about it all the
time confronting your dreams
so should she breathe covet air oh no
no no no not like that no so how do we
confront this having nightmares that i'm
in israel and i'm in situations where
like
everyone is everyone is not wearing a
mask i had a dream like that like
oh well that's it i got it there's
nothing i can do
is that what the card means honestly
yeah kind of so i'm not saying you
should go
breathe in covert air that's not very
well you did say confront yours it's
basically
investigate your psychological turmoil
so in go back into yourself and think
about
like that's a that is a very normal fear
to have right now
like getting covered is very serious
especially for people
who have children i feel like this is a
very cold
you know cold it's like a cold read you
know i don't i'm not you know what i
mean oh yeah but i haven't gotten
i mean if you want to stop then i can
but i mean there's
i have pulled quite a few cards out for
you oh boy
um let's get to the
what about the spirits are the spirits
talking to us let's get to the real
spooky [ __ ]
um did you can you do anything like
like like you know something that only
uh her
dad would know or something like can our
dad speak to her or something
could you have a hologram try channeling
um and i don't want to use dad's
hologram
no okay well not a hologram but um
your dad would your dad would come back
in a hologram and like be like
ethan's still wearing sandals
[Laughter]
um i actually did a reading
for zach not that long ago and um
i mean i don't know
i have what do you think what's your
what's your spiritual guidance should he
continue making tick tocks or not
i mean whatever makes him happy and gets
them out of his own way
[Music]
you know like there's a lot of um
struggles going on there
oh jesus
does that have a lover right now does
the card say anything about a lover
no and i'm not gonna delve into the
private
come on what are you there for if not
no not at this exact again that's wrong
i mean at the time that i did that
reading and
you know you know what we've talked
about but either way
i mean again my i've dealt with skeptics
my whole entire life and it's totally
fine i get it i do
channel though and um
he's yeah he's he's [ __ ] like crazy
right now as i understand it
no that's not true i mean that doesn't
yes but i do have to vouch for her she
did when i was vetting her
she wanted to give me a reading and she
did say something that i've never said
what did she say about you well it
wasn't about me specifically it was
about a person i lost
oh okay that's too personal i'm sorry
yeah yeah yeah can we get that with you
i just want okay you know what
thank you with peace and love thank you
for
i'm glad that you have this gift and uh
we wish you well i hope you find a
really good
effective treatment and yeah i'm really
sorry that you're going through that
that sounds horrible but
peace and love peace and love i'm ending
this call with peace and love
yeah you too thank you take care bye
does the ringo peace and love really
work on the i think it does
yeah it does okay i think it i like it
yeah zach
zach was just telling me about someone i
can't talk about it that's the thing
zack said i couldn't talk about
but so i had to put her to the test i
had to put her to the test
peace and love to her i really you know
my heart goes out
i'm i thought i i tried to warn her you
know
that could have gone worse for her but i
tried to warn her yeah
peace and love i should ask her if she
what what kind of king she has if she
puts on a diaper or anything i miss the
opportunity
uh there's all kinds of more videos you
guys want to keep going how much time we
got
we have been going for about an hour 50
so an hour we got any last minute calls
to bring in here
no one that sounds like a no should we
do a make ethan laugh
i know we're doing oh we're
because you uh you you pitched that
right at the beginning and there's a lot
more viewers now than before
so oh okay well on wednesday we're doing
our first ever episode of make ethan
laugh we are turning it into a
full-fledged
syndicated standalone show
where people call in they get one minute
to make me laugh
if they make me laugh they get 100 bucks
if you want to be
showcased contact zach on discord is
that right zach any further
yeah that is right and we have a few
great callers already lined up so if you
want to be a part of that
basically we need to fill like 30
minutes zach so that's probably i mean i
don't know how many callers there's
probably 10 12 15 but
if you don't make it we'll uh we'll
obviously
showcase you in the next one so queue up
and let's [ __ ] go make ethan laugh
all right
here oh i was wanting to watch this you
guys probably saw this i've seen this
video like
10 billion times
how many v but it's so funny um
so apparently this dude got a chocolate
fountain
but he tried to do a cheese fondue with
it
that looks like a good ass time by the
way what kind of cheese is that oh we
got the same haircut
kind of does that look like a good ass
time
just having a bunch of food whatever
what are you doing cheese cheese and
fried food yes dan yes anyway
here here's what happens when you put
cheese in a chocolate fountain
did he wait hold on dude are you serious
you know how it's supposed to like just
do a chocolate fountain did you really
think the cheese would
come down the fountain dude i mean what
the [ __ ] you thinking
what kind of cheese is that it's really
thick oh it's starting to go up you see
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
all of the cheese comes out what is this
cheese
dude it doesn't work like that it's way
too thick bro
dude that's like a that's like a full on
cheese assault
that's so funny
man i can't tell if he's happy or sad
man this was a crazy one something you
think of this hero
you said he had a sword i didn't see a
sword on him
who wrote that he had a sword he
definitely has this oh he does okay
so here's trump voters apparently in
trying to intimidate
people i mean clearly
where's the sword your mother voted for
trump
oh oh it's not it's like
it's like a set sword your mother loves
trump i asked her
he's still [ __ ] crazy though okay
is the card is the car covered in some
inflammatory like you know what i mean
like i feel like we're missing context
about why these people are so angry
but okay
[Music]
she cancelled
[Music]
[Applause]
we go okay you are now you're gonna vote
for trump whether you like it or not
you got no choice you cannot resist
trump we got you
we [ __ ] got it what a [ __ ] psycho
what could possibly elicit such a
psychotic response
we got you you don't have a choice
we got your plates oh boy
oh this one's fantastic this one's
inspiring it's like a
it's a modern-day uh disney fairy tale
[Music]
so this guy is basically the genie and
she is princess jasmine
he's going to put mud on her eyelashes
honey on her lips some more blush slaps
the [ __ ] out of her
so that her cheeks are rosy of course
[Music]
hey let's take care of you little man
an egg in the hair oh we heard about
this last week
taylor a little suit for the boy
well she ends up i mean impressed but it
doesn't fit him that good in the end
looks kind of big but okay whatever i'm
not going to hate
you know a little tie it made it a sock
very good now what pimp so pretty
why did water like burst out of his
mouth
so a modern-day uh fairy tale
interesting it's beautiful it is
beautiful beautiful man
god wow i feel like we've watched this
with the dude with the little brother
filming but anyway this is his little
brother ela
[Music]
that's his little [ __ ] brother
talk to me baby look at this
fro that's weird yeah that's weird
yeah that is a weird one
daughter sure i don't what did we just
watch
oh he's making a tick tock it's we've
we've seen his big dogs
and this is just maybe it's just to
explain
wait who you know his tick tock
well we've seen those kind of tick tocks
i kind of know the genre
i think somebody thought it was cool
maybe that how they
got it right that's a trend on tick tock
to do the bts when it's like cool how
they make the video
yeah that's not that ain't cool okay
dude oh this oh i'm so glad i didn't end
the show before i showed this
this is my favorite [ __ ] video of the
year dude
this is my video of the year do you
understand what i'm saying
and i almost missed this i am so upset
that i almost missed this but so glad
guys just
wait and watch
oh wow
i just peed in my basement
what is happening you'll see
god he's still can you see anything no i
mean i do but
what is this it's a fetish it is it's
gotta be look at his tight pant look how
tight his pants are
and he's recording it yeah it's a fetish
he's into it
oh my god there's pee all over the floor
by the way
wow wow
just posing with it
why people are so [ __ ] up man
people where did you find this one of
these guys found it
is it like a tick tock it's probably on
or what the [ __ ]
or something someone pulls down our
subreddit yeah
and said ethan has to see this and they
were right
yeah they're right i love this is my
favorite thing ever
yeah there's so much urine on the floor
usually i wouldn't keep shame or
anything but like damn you can't leave
urine on the floor dude but yeah i'm
sure this guy has some kind of website
and i think someone probably paid for
that video
i'm sure of it you know oh
that's so weird what is he is he just
going to walk out
yes that is so weird
i love that and his pants are so tight
and everything it's just
it's awesome and the waves posing
is this really what i think is going to
happen
that's great oh god
no are they just trying to get drunk
probably
that's some alcoholism right there this
is rock bottom
does that work i mean there's alcohol in
it i think it's pretty dangerous to do
but yeah
uh this is sad
yeah that's [ __ ] i just feel sad
watching that like damn give the guy a
beer man
that looked like russia too it's the
letters in the background god there's so
many there's so much content
all right i'm done god you're done i'm
done
guys it's halloween stay safe let's not
spread cover but let's have fun too you
know what i mean
swear masks socially distance be outside
if you're going to go outside stay away
from people
movie or something get tested and then
vote
god damn it vote this tuesday is the big
day
i'm super jacked i can't wait to see
what happens
can we just talk about alfredo for a
minute yeah he's so sweet
he's the sweetest most precious nicest
dog
you know wow i start to wake up lately
he was supposed to get groomed today
he's just like a walking fluff but i had
to cut that fur in front of his eyes
so he could see but now he's so cute
with his fur cut in front of his eyes
because he's just like a cotton ball
with eyes and nose
but i'm waking up recently and he comes
and lays next to me in my bed like
at the pillow because shredder kind of
we have like a bench at the end of the
bed that alfredo sits on because
shredder like alphas him off the bed and
then sometimes when shredder's sleeping
he'll come up and sleep next to me
he feels so bad for him shredder bullies
the [ __ ] out of that he's happy
fred's happy they're friends but they
play yeah fred gives it back to him
sometimes
that's good it is shredder's house i
mean
shut his house yeah shredders his rules
we all live by shredder's rules
that's kind of true shredder loves
alfredo though
he's so sweet you want to say hi to the
people here bring him over here
so we check on um alfred you won't say
anything
he's licking the mic should we check on
ai en and
uh a b nice that may be nice that
any closing words from you two
uh happy halloween stay safe all right
n-a-i-e everyone's candy cough in
people's face
death to all humans right let me yeah
you summed it up
cool next week what are we doing next
week we got uh we got a let's play a
monday among us with dunky and gus and
eddie and leah
tuesday tuesday do we have anything on
tunes well
tuesday will be for enemies and then
wednesday is making them laugh
wednesdays make even laughter thursdays
[ __ ] content court thursday is
content court
thursdays content court wait we have
five episodes next week
well yeah because we're adding one more
exciting
very exciting okay um
our guest too yeah contra points
yeah that'll be out the following week
though that'll come out on monday
so the following week so we don't which
is really exciting i'm i'm a fan
we all are there was uh comments on the
last episode
asking to get her so uh they'll be happy
it's happening what were we saying ab i
would say h3 out of context in the chat
said everybody go over to the h3
facebook page
oh yeah i keep straight i was amazed
everybody go we need
people to follow on facebook we're
trying to post
it's the h3 podcast facebook page we
need people to go like it because we're
trying to post clips there
and nobody [ __ ] watches them we get
like 10 likes on a post it's
embarrassing
because facebook facebook sucks yeah
facebook does suck but like i feel like
we have the most
growth potential there our instagram
page is doing pretty good but like
everybody just go like that [ __ ]
facebook page
not the h31 the h3 podcast facebook page
let's get 10 likes
gonna get 10 likes today on our next
post
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here yeah age credit context is spamming
it in the chat if you guys need the link
here let me go to the
i want to watch those likes go up boys
h3 podcast
facebook god facebook is such a dead
dumb platform
i hate it it is but no but like people
all these dumb idiots watch [ __ ] on
facebook so i'm trying to reach all
these idiots on facebook
well not you guys you guys are rule you
guys aren't dumb [ __ ]
but like these really dumb idiots all
these [ __ ] rules
you know it's like the cousin that is
exactly your aunt all these idiots they
go
oh they hd podcast they were just old
people in my neighborhood i made little
leaflets
yeah but like for example this clipper
bell
is great that's 16 likes do you
understand how pathetic we are
bell only 16 get on over there
we have one we have 4 700 likes come on
let's see what it's at now
oh yeah we got a hundred let's go
don't do it shut up damn we're trying to
grow the show
okay boomer trying to harvest all the
facebook [ __ ]
but like do any of you guys use facebook
like on a regular basis
i don't log in there at all nope but
it's still like
you know it's still so dominant
and all these people like joey salads
are making like
ungodly money there so
not anymore right it's only boomers on
facebook yeah
boomerang boomers are good
boomer dollars are good dollars i just
used to talk to family that's
it i used to do that and i'm
i can't even do that anymore i use
what's up for family communication now i
love what's up
also facebook okay boomer so how many
more do we got i'm gonna sit here until
we get
i'm not ending the show until we get
five thousand
we're almost there wait oh five thousand
total
thousand yeah five thousand new likes i
was like
everybody i want every single person not
gonna end it
all right guys have a fantastic time
and a really good weekend and uh
see you next week we got five freaking
episodes man how cool is that
next week you get some rest these weeks
are long man
why is it that if you go to the
community there's more people
following it than like it what does that
mean because facebook is
the dumbest platform on the internet it
has two
separate things to what does it mean
yeah what does it i don't know the exact
difference but there is
there's following and there's liking and
those are two
i don't like this i just want to hate on
it i guess
so following is if you want to [ __ ] on
something but not like
i'm glad you'll see the updates about it
i believe and if you like it it will
show up on your page is like your
interests
sure yeah facebook sucks i hate you
[ __ ] you mark zuckerberg is a douche
he really is such a douche you guys are
really gonna use a platform run by that
idiot
you can't pick up your mind hold on hold
on
what am i not going to promote facebook
it's like a [ __ ]
social jugger juggernaut i just don't
like the platform
but it's useful for harvesting the
idiots on there yeah
suck and i want them all we need views
oh here we go
i love it all right guys we'll see you
i'm excited let's get that election
let's go vote let's go
vote
all right vote all right guys take care
we'll see you next
be the best time in the world take it
from me jc
over cherry hp baby we podcasting now
you're watching x to the three three
three three you're watching h two
three three three
[Music]
my drinks are made while the incest
honestly shredder was not barking off
regardless at the sweet we'll do the
real raw ritual with more and e.t
share a laugh with the ringer see how
low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but we
always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two